a lot of celebrities got involved in
this election that was hilarious to me
like that they thought that I was gonna
change my vote because somebody from
eight ways to talk to your mother goes
oh yeah you know I'm kind of liking
Bernie Sanders it's just like who are
you you're an actor why would I listen
to you yeah yeah that's a big phenomenon
in our culture though celebrities coming
out and saying you know this is what we
thinks you should vote for and it feels
like it's it's kind of becoming apparent
that I think you've heard all the
candidates you think it hurts I think it
hurts them to sit there and it I just
start out here people got real late
they're really smug and talked down to
flyover States like they're a bunch of
morons and and I don't think they and
then I think it goes back to the
candidate I don't think you're helping
him I don't think anybody who's any sort
of intelligent person you know decides
who they're gonna vote for because the
guy who pretended to be a Shogun you
know in some movie told you to do it
we're talking about who should lead the
free world some of the strangest
celebrity references I've ever heard i
watch sports i know you know i always
flip through and i see you know people
with swords and i'm like alright that's
in now okay that's probably why it's not
working on you i mentioned earlier as i
watch sports yeah and the thing that
concerned me the most in sports was i
watch cleveland play a home game in
november and it was 71 degrees up and
the pictures were sweating and all that
no that's not a good thing people this
is the Golden Age of global warming so
yeah take it in stick your arm out the
window before the Hellfires come I was
nice to cheer up the crowd you know
I should have canceled this is like the
weirdest day ever
you should have moved this show don't
know I like I played it you here ok wait
you here because we're talking about ok
you